[Musique]
bonjour général dominique trinquant
bonjour ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'onu
nous sommes au neuvième jour de cette
guerre en ukraine on a entendu hier le
président russe vladimir poutine dire
que sa guerre se déroule comme prévu or
nombre d'éléments sur le terrain tente à
prouver le contraire quel est l'objectif
de ce discours selon voix qui est il
destiné je pense que ce discours est là
pour arrêter et dissiper les états
hésitent à sion consent mais consent
surtout à propos de kiev parce qu'à
ailleurs le président poutine a raison
tout se déroule comme il le prévoyait la
mer d'azov est devenu russe la mer noire
la
la face nord de la mer noire commence à
être us la partie est du donbass
commence à être contrôlés sérieusement
par donc tout ce qui est à l'est
j'allais dire du nieppe
passe plus ou moins sous contrôle russe
la seule question c'est évidemment kiev
dont il espérait que ça tomberait comme
un fruit mûr rapidement qu'ils
changeraient de gouvernement rapidement
là il a échoué et on voit bien que la
population se prépare à défendre kiev
qui est toujours pas tombée on n'imagine
pas que la russie lui réserve le même
sort que grozny par exemple la plus
vieux d'entre nous s'en souviendront
peut-être l'armée russe dont on connaît
la puissance de feu est ce qu'elle a
gêné alors elle est gênée pour prendre
kiev bien sûr parce que la méthode
grosse ni c'est simple on rase tout et
on prend la ville à kiev ça ne peut pas
se passer de la fin de la même façon
kiev est symboliquement très importante
pour les russes le président poutine
dans sa propagande a annoncé qu'il
allait libérer les frères ukrainiens
d'un génocide
face à des fantoches tenus par les états
unis dont qui il doit avoir beaucoup de
précautions pour la prise de kiev or le
combat en zone urbaine est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile on voit la
population ukrainienne très déterminé
donc ça nécessite vraiment beaucoup de
force et beaucoup de temps or le temps
et contre le président poutine plus le
temps passe plus la police la population
russe commence à avoir les nums mauvaise
nouvelle et plus et mauvais d'ailleurs
on voit bien dans son discours hier où
il a commencé à parler des pensions des
soldats c'est incroyable au milieu d'une
offensive de parler de ça justement sur
le coût humain de cette guerre dominique
train quand les civils d'abord il n'y a
pas moyen à l'heure qu'il est d'avoir
des chiffres précis on parle de
centaines de milliers de morts et
comment aider les civils qui fuient ce
conflit hier les deux parties se sont
retrouvées pour
parler de couloir humanitaire organisé
pratiquement comment ça peut se faire
alors les couloirs humanitaires c'est la
tarte à la crème qu'on sort à chaque
fois dans une négociation quand on ne
sait pas quoi faire on sort des couloirs
humanitaires
on a l'impression de s'occuper de la
population en même temps c'est une
stratégie puisque un cessez le feu à un
moment pour faire sortir la population
permet de positionner différemment les
troupes ceci étant la population est
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
parce que pour faire tomber les villes
en fait avant de donner un assaut qu'est
ce qu'on fait on l'encerclent on coupe
l'électricité
on coupe l'eau il ya plus de carburant
les gens ne peuvent plus sortir d'argent
et donc se trouve affamés sans aucun
moyen et donc au bout d'un moment on le
voit dans certaines villes ukrainiennes
qui tombe actuellement
sous le joug russe
c'est une façon de le faire tomber donc
les couloirs humanitaires ça va
permettre d'exfiltrer les populations au
passage ça concourt à l'objectif de
guerre russe c'est à dire que les
populations quittent les villes donc ça
permet de prendre les villes et puis ça
étouffe complètement l'ukraine qu'elle
admire poutine a accusé les combattants
ukrainien de se battre comme des lâches
en prenant ce sont ses mots et les
civils comme boucliers humains
les pertes civiles on vient d'évoquer
les pertes militaires l'ukraine dit
avoir tué six mille soldats russes dans
la guerre soviétiques en afghanistan
c'est quinze mille soldats russes et
moscou ne reconnaître que 500 morts s'il
est vrai qu'on ne peut pas à l'heure
qu'il est avoir de chiffres précis
qu'est ce que tout de même ces chiffres
de sens mort par exemple de soldats ruiz
dirais à l'échelle d'un conflit comme
celui ci alors écoutez ça ne fait qu'une
semaine que la guerre a commencé en
ukraine donc ce sont de grosses pertes
pour l'armée russe je pense que plus que
les morts il y a aussi les prisonniers
et les ukrainiens utilise très très bien
les vidéos des prisonniers qui sont
complètement décontenancé parce qu'ils
pensaient être en manoeuvre il pensait
pas aller faire la guerre c'est le
premier point ensuite ils sont mal
ravitailler ce sont les ukrainiens qui
leur donne à boire et à manger et un
téléphone portable pour appeler leur
mère et raconter à leur mère en russie
ce qui se passe donc là on est vraiment
dans une guerre de communication très
bien utilisé par les ukrainiens et puis
vous avez raison le problème du nombre
de morts évidemment les chiffres sont
faux probablement des deux côtés les
russes diminue les ukrainiens augmente
de façon à montrer que la guerre ça
reste la guerre et ça tue la guerre est
aussi affaire de narration qu'elle passe
au qu'elle ne passe pas on a le
sentiment que la narration de vladimir
poutine ne passe pas auprès d'être d'une
partie de son opinion publique est ce
que selon vous c'est une négligence ou
au contraire ils s'en moquent totalement
je pense qu'il n'est pas sensible je
pense pas qu'ils s'en moquent mais il
est absolument pas sensible à
l'impression que ça fait dans la russie
lui il est sur son objectif mais il a
fait une erreur considérable dans la
communication c'est de croire que
d'abord de réécrire l'histoire de
l'ukraine et ensuite de croire que
finalement tout ce ciel espace et
facilement il ya une vidéo qui est passé
hier que j'ai vu qui est très
intéressante où il sort d'un conseil où
il était avec le ministre et la défense
et le chef d'état major qui lui avait
promis une guerre éclair et évidemment
ça n'est pas une guerre éclair et donc
il est absolument furieux et pour se
calmer il marche tout seul dans les rues
avec bien sur ses gardes du corps autour
mais dont qu'il avait fait une erreur de
perception l'ukraine devaient être
saisis parce que les ukrainiens ne
voulait pas du gouvernement fantoche
zelensky faut le président hélène ce qui
est au coeur de la résistance les
ukrainiens veut lutter avec l'ukraine et
c'est la mauvaise perception qu'il a en
croyant que la russie et l'ukraine c'est
pareil non l'ukraine est une nation et
elle a envie de rester indépendante il a
dit hier que la russie et l'ukraine
était un seul et même peuple emmanuel
macron qui vient d'officialiser sa
candidature dit vouloir rester en
contact en tout cas c'était le cas hier
avec le président poutine pour lui dire
quoi quand vladimir poutine dit qu'il va
jusqu'au bout alors premier point
toujours gardé une ligne de contact
c'est un principe essentiel en
diplomatie alors ya les ukrainiens et
les russes qui négocient dans leur coin
toujours utile et puis le président
russe est complètement enfermé dans sa
logique or il ya un homme qui arrive à
lui parler c'est le président macron au
passage hier c'est le président ma
poutine qui a pris l'initiative de
téléphoner à macron après qu'on lui ait
rendu compte de l'intervention télévisée
très très durs du président macron donc
c'est important ce sont deux hommes qui
sont sur des planètes un peu différente
mais le président macron
continue à discuter comme disait le
prince d'orange il n'est pas nécessaire
d'espérer pour entreprendre ni de
réussir pour persévérer
le président macron persévère et il a
raison vladimir poutine général train
caen n'a eu de cesse de réitérer ces
conditions une ukraine neutre qui nous
rejoignent jamais l'otan un changement
de régime qui lui soit favorable face à
de telles conditions qu'elles avançaient
sur le plan diplomatique
alors je pense que la halle avancée
diplomatique va être en fonction de
l'avancée des militaires sur le terrain
c est à dire que la saisie des points
sur la mer noire la progression dans le
donbass coupe en fait l'ukraine de
toutes les forces vives de tout ce qui
lui permet de vivre
au bout du compte le fait une guerre
économique c'est une guerre économique
complètement au bout du compte le
président poutine je crois est en train
de réaliser qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement de gouvernement comme il le
souhaitait
il a fait dire par son porte parole
avant-hier que le président hélène ce
qui était le président légal de
l'ukraine c'est une révolution quand
même donc je pense que là il n'y arrive
pas la question qui reste une
interrogation pour moi est que faire à
hauteur de kiev est-ce que la sauv ait
donné sur kiev ce qui sera
catastrophique et pour le cren et pour
la russie où est ce que finalement la
pression sera suffisante pour amener à
des négociations général rien quand je
m'adresse aux militaires que vous êtes
est ce qu'il y a des co belligérants
dans cette guerre là aussi on prenait
les bataillon tchétchène on connaît le
bélarus on connaît mais en phase avec le
prennent au côté de l'ukraine est ce
qu'il y a des forces exogènes alors il
n'y a pas de forces exogènes mais il ya
un soutien très fort de l'union
européenne et de l'otan très très
clairement alors un soutien très jusqu'à
aider l'ukraine à avoir une partie de
son espace aérien non l'espace aérien
est un autre sujet le contrôle de
l'espace aérien demandée par le
président zine qui s'éteint en starter
si j'ose dire en employant le langage
otanien pourquoi parce que seul le temps
est capable de contrôler l'espace il
pourrait le faire
seulement là c'est l'entrée en guerre de
l'otan et face à la russie et ça
personne ne le veut la dernière le
dernier contrôle d'espacés aériens que
nous avions fait c'était en ex
yougoslavie
ça demande des moyens considérables
contrôle aérien chasseurs en l'air qui
ravitaillait ravitaillait bien sûr c'est
des moyens considérables il ya que le
temps qui est capable de faire ça dans
cette région et ça ça c'est la
confrontation directe avec la russie je
pense que personne ne franchira spa
l'onu enfin une maison vous connaissez
bien elle a dit cette semaine dans sa
résolution ce qu'elle souhaitait sauf
que alors
résolution de l'assemblée générale cent
quarante et une voix c'est considérable
ça montre qu'il ya vraiment un mouvement
contre l'invasion russe intéressant de
noter la chine parce que la chine
sapiens elle ne va pas jusqu'à soutenir
alors qu'elle avait soutenu un peu au
départ l'opération en russe
reconnaissant les problèmes russes mais
aujourd'hui la chine qu'est ce qu'elle
fait il guigne et lyon
elle veut avoir des contrats avec la
russie qui va lui fournir du pétrole du
gaz et des mines et ray mais elle a
besoin de commercer avec l'ensemble du
monde donc elle est entre les deux et
donc elle te veux poutine le
gouvernement russe devient un instrument
entre les mains de la chine donc celle
inverse est plutôt la russie qui est
obligé de se tourner contre la chine que
la chine obligés de se tourner contre la
russie merci beaucoup derrière dominique
trinquant d'être venu jusqu'à l'os et
elle était l'invitée de pareilles direct
ancien chef de la mission militaire
française auprès de l'onu